a computer is hidden inside this dress
it controls an LED display which lights
up in accordance with the wearer's
heartbeat sensors monitor the pulse the
data is sent to a microcontroller which
fords the signal to the LED display
berlin-based designer Lena VAR song
created the dress for 2 years now she's
been working to fuse fashion and
technology and she's interested in
having clothes react to the human body
our muscles are constantly working but
we don't realize how and now we can
start wearing something that shows what
our muscles are doing that's exciting
lack of human form to need and this is
their function intelligent clothing is
all the rage Dutch designer for acoustic
has developed a high tech overall that
turns humans into walking Wi-Fi hotspots
this garment is fitted with solar panels
wearers can use the power generated to
charge their cell phones another example
of functional high-tech clothing it's
the creation of Dutch designer Polina
pond donggun she's named her clothing
line
wearable solar and wants to make
high-tech fashion mainstream I think
still so for quite a lot of people it's
a far-fetched scenario so we need to
show them what the potential is and what
it can mean to them like in the
beginning of the time that the computer
came or the mobile phone people also
didn't realize what what it could mean
to them by now we can't do without them
and I think the same will happen with
wearable tech 75 years ago portable
computers were unthinkable in 1941 conf
at Susa developed the first ever
programmable computer the z3 it weighed
roughly a ton up until the 1950s data
were still entered using punch cards
beginning in the 1970s powerful
processors made computers more common in
1981 IBM launched the first home
computer
the IBM 5150 soon after the Apple
Macintosh was launched the first
computer with a graphic display pretty
quickly the World Wide Web became a
mainstream phenomenon finally laptops
and then smartphones assured in the
mobile internet era nobody thinks about
the fact that the iPhone is a
technological device because it's
something we use every day it's become a
companion in our everyday social life
one reason for this is how products are
designed over the decades computers have
become smaller and more portable but
also more colorful Apple turned
computers into lifestyle products and
status symbols when it launched machines
in brightly colored casings in the 1990s
and it revolutionized the way humans and
machines interact when it released the
iPhone and iPad - after me this design I
thought I could almost fly by de Vie I
think design should progress even
further right now we still need to learn
to use these devices we're not used to
typing clicking or tapping instead we're
more used to gesticulating speaking and
listening so I think designs will
progress in that direction increasingly
we're witnessing the fusion of human
bodies and Technology wearables
represent a growth market smartwatches
and fitness trackers measure our pulse
how far we've walked and how many
calories we've burned smartphone apps
and hours to analyze the data and he
neva song thinks this is just the
beginning
so I'm gonna start of NZ it would be
great to see wearables and fashion tech
respond to our physical needs so that
for example in winter our clothes would
recognize when we're cold and switch on
the heating and yeah try to be hide some
on the computer has revolutionized the
way we work and play no other devices
changed our lives so profoundly